is there a rule which you didn't write
in the original list of 42 that you wish
you'd put in there set aside some time
for play that's one can I make a
suggestion from your work sure it's from
a lecture that you gave don't practice
what you do not want to become I have a
corollary of that too that works in
relationships do not punish what you
want to have happen so here's an example
imagine that you've married someone that
you find attractive and then imagine
that other people find that person
attractive as well and that that's
actually somewhat threatening to you and
then instead of dealing with the fact
that you're threatened by the very thing
that you were attracted to and that
you're blessed to have you start to
punish the person that you're with when
they manifest themselves as attractive
well you do that for 10 years and the
attractive person is no longer there and
then you're going to be angry at them
even though it was completely your fault
it's very common for people to
experience punishment for their virtue
you know because if you punish someone
for the manifestation of a desirable
virtue it really hurts them